I don't know whether this is going to
make a difference or not however he's
standing up
[Music]
[Applause]
America's Got Talent is only two weeks
into season 18 and Simon Cowell has
already handed out his coveted Golden
Buzzer you're gonna see every possible
kind of act in the world just go with
your gut you know you're going to
remember this clip this audition for
many many years to come I'm sure of that
during Tuesday's episode 17 year old
Indonesian singer-songwriter putri
ariani took the stage my dream is being
a biggest defy in the world like when
the Houston and win Grammy Award but the
teen explained that one of the big
hurdles standing in her way my biggest
challenge is people look at me just as a
blind person not as a musician but when
I'm singing I feel like a superstar once
she started singing it was clear she is
a superstar
[Music]
oh
it's really about the people it's about
the acts that come here and give their
all and show all their courage I'm
always inspired just by watching people
give everything they have for their
dream it's a it's a beautiful experience
oh and we should mention that was an
original song and Simon well I just said
saputra I like her voice so much thank
you to sing a second Zone please
it's special for you Simon and song
number two was just as impressive
[Music]
the 17
you write songs you've got an amazing
distinctive voice thank you I mean
really really good in fact Simon thought
it was so good he slammed on the golden
buzzer securing her spot in the live
shows
I like being surprised you know
fortunately people come from all over
the world now to audition for the show
so you're never going to run out of
talent
um
better not otherwise we don't have a
show leading up to the show's Premiere
ET chatted with host Terry Crews who
teased that fans can expect some epic
Talent this year I always have thought
that I've seen it all and then somebody
comes and blows it all away there is no
end to human potential and I'm always
shocked I'm always surprised I'm always
my heart is always full of the wonderful
stories of ordinary Americans ordinary
citizens doing amazing things that it
will never get old it's one of the most
beautiful things that we could ever see
[Music]